Mandy Moore is also speaking out the
star add this is us is for dealing in
detail the trauma she claims she
suffered because of her ex-husband the
picture Mandy Moore paints of her seven
year marriage to singer Ryan Adams is
filled with disturbing allegations of
psychological abuse control and
isolation saying quote his controlling
behavior essentially did block my
ability to make new connections in the
industry during a very pivotal and
potentially lucrative time
[Music]
the two married in 2009 when she was 24
the divorce was finalized in 2016 when
she was 32 an attorney for Adams deny
his Mandy's allegations calling them
quote inconsistent with his view of the
relationship
Mandy's revelations were part of a New
York Times article in which six other
women accused her ex husband of
harassment emotional abuse and a times
career sabotage Bryan has vehemently
denied all the allegations Adams is a
rock musician who in 2015 gained
mainstream attention covering Taylor
Swift's 1989 album here he is performing
blank space on The Daily Show you know
when you know actors say a line they say
a sentence but they say it with
different emphasis on different words
and completely change it that's what you
did with my album after Mandy and Ryan
announced their split in 2015 she wasted
no time reclaiming her career check she
was cast ten months later in her Golden
Globe nominated role and this is us
she has also happily remarried to singer
Taylor goldsmith after the New York
Times article published Mandy took to
Instagram and said quote speaking your
truth can be painful and triggering but
it's always worth it well Mandy says
that her heart is with all women who
have suffered any kind of trauma or
abuse
[Applause]
[Music]